passionne.
♪ ♪ ♪
construite en 1781 au bord
du Richelieu.
La visite bien documentée
d'un prince britannique à Sorel
Et des fouilles archéologiques
menées en juin dernier.
YVES CHRÉTIEN, archéologue
- Je savais qu'il y avait là
du 18e siècle. Pour moi,
c'est un potentiel d'un trésor
archéologique qui se trouvait
à cet endroit
- L'archéologue, Yves Chrétien,
débarque à Sorel-Tracy en 2017
pour sonder le terrain autour g,
avant que la Ville n'y fasse
des travaux d'aménagement.
40 coups de sonde, dontun plein,
sous l'îlot 'îlot 'îlot 'îlot '.
- Rend5 mètre,
tout d'un coup, j'arrive
mais là, il y en avait,
ça avait aucun sens.
Tout était mélangé :erie, le ve,
les ossements d'animaux,
des coquilles d'huitres.
- La table est mise
fantastique que la ville
de Sorel-Tracy a d'abord
partagée avec les citoyens.
qu'ils avaient trouvé.
Mais lt plus que
ce qu'on s'attendait.
- C'est ce qui est surprenréussr
autant de morceaux, puis
pouvoir toutes les remettre
toutes ensemble.
identifié en 2017, a donc révélé
ses trésors l'été dernier,
quand les archéologues sont
revenus faire une fouille- On at
la cible, elle était là.
on trouvait... c'est sûrqu'ils ,
mais les morceaux étaient tous
c'est l'indice que les pièces
ont été jetées complètes
dans la fosse, telles quelles.
40 bouteilles de vin.
- Je suis très impressionné,
très impressionné.
SERGE Tracy
- C'est fou la quantité,
le nombre, puis la qualité
des pièces, puis l'état aussi.
aussi est impressionné.
- C'est du Creamware, ça.
C'est une céramique qui était
en vogue à cette époque-là
Les morceaux étaient tous
en articulation. C'est que
ils ont jeté la vaisselle
sans la laver.
- Oui, ils jetaient tout.
- Un comportemen
intrigant.
- Alors, c'est un comportement
Et là, justement, on se pose
la quece
que c'est que ça?
- La vaisselle, les bouteilles
de table révèlent le caractère
inusitnquet
et l'importance des convives.
D'autres indices, comme le type
d'établir une fourchettede temp.
- Si on regarde dans la périodeu
un événement historique marquant
Et la réponse est oui,
c'est la présence, la visite
du Pri
le 18 septembre 1787.
- Il reste des recherches
confirmer l'hypothèse
du banquet royal.
PATRICK PÉLOQUIN, historien, et
- C'est un trésor, c'est
vraiment de trouver vraiment
le plus gros cadeau historique
dans la région. En fait,
ça vient confirmer l'utilisation
de la maison, ici, la Maison
des goà-dire que c'était
vraiment un lieu pour
les dignitaires de la province
de Québec.
les garder, puis que ça va
être en démonstration,
pour montrer aux gens
que ça vient d'ici, puisdu banq.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Sorel s'est appelée
William Henry pendant
Aujourd'hui, la visite
du jeune prince,
roi de Grande-Bretagne
est devenue beaucoup.
Ici Anne-Louis Despatie,
Radio-Canada, Sorel-Tracy.